grab your pencils Democrats today is the
last day for Biden supporters to
convince folks in New Hampshire to write
in the name Joe Biden after Joe took his
name off the ballot to prioritize the
race in South Carolina you follow that
the Secretary of State's office says as
long as the intent of the name is clear
the vote will likely count for Biden
we're not sure if the big guy or corn
poop was a bad dude we'll make the cut
but it's a fun little way to make sure
Biden wins the primary and avoid an
embarrassing loss to democratic
Challenger Dean
Phillips sadly it's going to demonstrate
that our incumbent president is
unelectable and weak and I think it's
going to show this country that there's
a candidate here who can actually do
what has been promised for Generation I
think Joe Biden's a good man but to your
point he's not standing in front of the
press he's not here meeting voters he's
not answering questions he's not doing
town halls and he won't do debates I
think he's a good man I don't think he
has a cognitive issue but he's he's 81
years old he's in Decline meanwhile
recent polls indicate that black voters
are sour ing on Biden over issues like
the economy but Jim kurn wants to blame
that on
misinformation I'm concerned with the
reporting to this yes when I see those
numbers you know my goodness if there's
any truth to the numbers which I don't
believe them because I talk to black
people all the time I don't know where
the numbers are coming from but when you
ask a question and someone is basing
their opinion on incomplete information
or misinformation
there's a lot of misinformation going on
out here there a lot of things being
said that's just not true you know I
also talk to black people all the time
I.E
heral uh what do you do you actually
believe that it's
misinformation I don't I I take polls
for when when you when you when you see
a poll you gotta if you don't believe it
that it may be right you got to look at
the the particulars of it I I think that
poll is probably accurate I do think
that once you get into a a join race
between Trump and Biden maybe those
numbers change a bit but I think we
ignore those numbers at our own Peril um
we've set on this show for many times
and I have like I I think if six months
from today the economy is better
consumer sentiment is improving and it
is improving right now if it continues
on this path any incumbent president
would be in a much better position as
they head into a general election uh if
gas prices we I think that is a big
moniker where that is on Memorial Day uh
will have a a big say or I should say
it's an indicator what may happen in the
election but it is it is I think
shortsighted and maybe misguided and I
think president B President Obama is
even shared with President Biden that
he's got to think about this thing more
seriously and the campaign has got to be
more agile and got to be more
substantive and speak to these voters uh
this is the right way to lose these
voters the correct way to go about this
is to believe the poll and to to to
craft a strategy to help reverse those
numbers judge uh so there's this whole
right in effort do you think Joe forgot
that he was behind this Chang at the
beginning and he doesn't remember I'm so
glad you asked me that question Craig
because here's the deal Joe Biden
decides he wants to change the rules for
a hundred years New Hampshire has been
the first state in the presidential
primary okay so Joe gets his Pals at the
DNC to change the rules you know the DNC
they're the ones who like helped Hillary
along and got rid of Sanders you
remember this right but that's not a
question that's just you can rhetorical
okay so he directs the DNC to change the
rules so South Carolina goes first why
because South Carolina is where he wins
with Jim klyburn and according to this
guy Phillips if you're 81 and in Decline
clyburn's 83 and in Decline that might
explain why he doesn't understand the
polls so he directs the DNC to have
South Carolina go first but then he says
oh my gosh since New Hampshire has a
state law which requires that they go
now he says okay uh what we're going to
do is is we're going to make sure that
we get people to write me in so I don't
lose to uh Williamson and Dean Phillips
so people in New Hampshire are saying
Poor Joe the DNC changed it New
Hampshire won't go along no Joe changed
it so here we go the DNC says no
delegates will be awarded based on what
happens in New Hampshire and Biden is
unwilling to debate he doesn't even want
to be in New Hampshire he's not going to
go there he wants to be coronated and we
know what happened last time the last
Democratic candidate wanted to be
coronated that be Hillary so anyway as
it relates to Clyburn okay 50 if you're
under 50 32% of the blacks are with you
and if you're over 50 65% are with you
and that's a real problem for Joe Biden
I don't think he's going to do as well
as he thinks he's going to do in South
Carolina Jesse uh so Joe's asking people
to write in his name perhaps because
that's what Jill does on his name tag in
case he ever gets lost what are you
going to be filling in Joe Biden's name
would you vote no in the interest of
full transparency my uncle is in charge
of the right in for Biden campaign here
in New Hampshire he's a Democrat you
guessed it state senator here and I just
got off the phone with him and he said
they had to do it because the rule is in
the state constitution they have to have
a primary the DNC made a dumb decision
and they just wanted to show their
support for Joe Biden so they raised
money for signs and for all the
Grassroots efforts I say is this thing
going to be close is he barely going to
put away this Dean character and he goes
I don't care if he wins by one vote it's
fine with me and Greg I also talk to
black people too and Harold tells me
that black Americans are not happy with
Joe Biden the only thing that they've
delivered to the black community is a
legals oh there you go I got to write
that down last word to you Dana uh
writing in my name is that uh is that
effective
campaigning it's actually a good idea I
mean why not give it a shot gutfeld's
easy to spell interesting I heard today
from this guy we had on Newsroom his
name is Nick Lake and he's part of the
New Hampshire Institute of politics and
apparently when they first put out the
advertisement about doing the writing
campaign they spelled Biden's name
wrong which might be why you could just
mark an X and they'll be like okay cool
that's for Biden it is embarrassing for
Biden to have to do this he listened to
the far-left members and the activists
of his party who said New Hampshire's
just too white what's interesting is
that New Hampshire has a lot of history
one we've already established that but
there are many college educated white
people who live in New Hampshire and
that is making up a big part of the
president's base so he should want to
make sure that they are happy I do think
Biden might eek it out but we're talking
about the how New Hampshire can often
surprise maybe the surprise isn't on the
Republican side this time around it
could be on the Democratic side so I'll
be watching that and Bill hemmer at the
bill board
tomorrow alrighty then coming up Joe
Biden makes a stunning admission on the
open border hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else